كيران كوازي فتى امريكي يبلغ من العمر 14
عام هو اصغر خريجي الجامعات على الاطلاق
بهذا السن وهو ايضا موظف في شركه سبيس اكس
المملوكه لايلون ماسك هذا التقدم المهني
والعلمي ليس غريب لطفل بدا يتحدث ويكون
ويكون جملا كامله وهو في عمر عامين بس
طبعا اسره كيران ادركت ان معدل ذكاء مرتفع
جدا بنسبه تصل الى
99.9% ما شاء الله وهو في التاسعه من عمره
التحق بجامعات سانتا كلارا لدراسه علوم
وهندسه الكمبيوتر في عمر الحادي عشر واجرى
مقابله مع ستار لينك خدمه الانترنت في
شركه سبيس اكس وسيبدا العمل
الشهر القادم مبروك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات